I want to talk to you today about what I
think is a relatively new way of looking
at your experience,
but maybe even more broadly than that in
a new way of looking at reality itself.
You all come to university,
I suppose to make your conceptions of
reality more sophisticated and you want
to do that because you have to live in
the world and the more sophisticated
your conceptions,
the less likely you'll encounter tragic
or harmful circumstances that you will
be unable to deal with.
It really matters if you know what
you're thinking and you know how to
think.
Over the last 20 years,
I would say there's been a revolution in
psychology and the revolution has
involved a transformation in the way
that we look at the world and that's
what I want to talk to you about today.
I've entitled this talk reality and the
sacred.
It's a strange title for a talk to
modern people because we don't really
understand what the sacred means unless
we live within a worldview that says
essentially,
I wouldn't say archaic,
but at least traditional for modern free
thinking.
Fundamentally liberal people.
The idea of the sacred is anachronistic
or if not anachronistic,
at least incomprehensible.
So I want.
I want to start with a story from the
Old Testament.
There's a scene in the old testament
when the ancient Hebrews are moving the
Ark of the covenant and the Ark of the
covenant is a device that was
manufactured in order to contain the
word of God and there was a rule among
the ancient Hebrews which was you were
not to touch the Ark of the covenant no
matter what,
and there's a story in the old testament
were the bearers of the Ark of the
covenant.
They used to carry it,
the bearers of the Ark of the covenant
trip,
and a man reaches out to steady it and
when he touches it,
God strikes them dead and modern.
People look at a story like that and the
first thing they think is a that seems a
little bit harsh on the part of God,
given that the man was attempting to do
something that he believed was good,
but what the story is designed to
indicate,
in my opinion,
is that there are certain things that
you touch at your peril,
regardless of your intentions and those
things that you touch at your peril,
regardless of your intentions.
Most cultures regard as sacred,
as untouchable.
I want to make a case for you today that
those things exist and also why they
exist and why it's necessary for you to
know that they exist.
I would also say that if you're properly
educated in the university,
especially with regards to the
humanities which are in some conceptual
trouble at the moment,
what you are,
what essentially happens to you is that
you're introduced in a relatively
secular way to the concept of the
sacred.
You're here in the university to learn
about the eternal values of humankind,
and I think that people who tell you
that those values do not exist or that
they're endlessly debatable.
Do you an an unbelievable disservice?
Now I'm going to tell you first how you
think about the world.
I think so.
This would be a Newtonian view of the
world.
It's Newtonian and deterministic and
it's a worldview that dominated
psychology and economics and
anthropology and political science.
You name it for probably 400 years,
but it's coming to a crashing halt in
the last 50 years,
and the consequence of that consequences
of that have been manifested in a number
of domains.
The old world presuppositions or
something like this.
The world is made out of objects.
When you look at the world,
you see the objects,
they are,
they are in front of you as a
consequence of seeing the objects.
You think about what to do and after you
think about what to do in presence of
the objects you act.
Now that seems self evident because when
you look at the world,
there are the objects are and it appears
to you that you see them and then you
think about them and then you act,
but there's a real problem with that.
First problem is use half your brain to
see literally human visual Cortex is
very large part of your brain and the
reason that the visual cortex is so
large is that seeing is as far as we can
tell actually impossible now,
the fact that seeing perception is
impossible,
it wasn't discovered by psychologists
and it wasn't discovered by
philosophers,
was discovered by people who are
working,
who were working on artificial
intelligence and trying to make
artificially intelligent machines.
The presupposition of the people who
were making intelligent machines was the
hardest part of interacting with the
world is figuring out what to do once
you see the objects,
but it turned out that making machines
that could see objects was impossible,
and the reason for that is that
boundaries between objects are not
obvious.
They're not obvious at all.
In fact,
it's very difficult to understand how it
is that we separate things up at all.
I'll let me give you an example.
So if you think about yourself,
when you look in the mirror,
you see yourself as an object.
You see your eyes,
you see your nose,
you see your face,
you see your body,
and that's pretty much what you see when
you look at other people,
but that isn't all there is to you.
In fact,
that's hardly any of what there is to
you,
so you could say,
for example,
you exist at the level of the quantum
particle.
You can't perceive that in fact,
people didn't know that until 75 years
ago.
Above that level,
you exist at an atomic level and then a
molecular level and then you exist at
the level of complex organs and then the
interactions between those organs and
then you and then your family and then
the groups that your family belonged to
and then the ecosystem that the groups
of your are that that all your groups
belong to and on and so on,
so on and so forth until what it is that
you are can expand to encompass
virtually anything.
Now,
when you look at yourself,
you don't see that.
You see yourself at a certain level of
resolution.
When you look at the world,
you see yourself at a certain level of
resolution,
but all those other levels are equally
real and equally relevant and Lee in
fact have very little idea how it is
that you're only able to see what you
see.
Almost nothing has obvious boundaries
and this has real world consequences.
It's not something that's merely
abstract the technical term for this
problem.
No problem of how to bind your
perceptions to limit them is called the
frame problem framing problem was
discovered about 40 years ago and the
philosopher Daniel Dennett called it the
most important philosophical discussion,
a discovery of the last 50 years.
The frame problem emerges to cause all
sorts of trouble for people.
So for example,
when Henry Ford invented the automobile,
well at least invented the modern
procedure of building the automobile.
What Ford presumed was that he was
building an efficient means of
transporting people from one place to
the other.
There were other unintended consequences
affords discovery.
So for example,
for it happened to be a great supporter
of fascism and the reason that he was a
supporter of fascism bit wasn't because
he regarded the Fascia fascist political
structure as a logical extension of the
efficient methods that he'd used to
assemble vehicles.
So his motive production was instantly
manifested in a political philosophy.
Furthermore,
now 2009,
100 years after the invention of the
automobile,
we've discovered some other things that
the car was other than a place to move
people from point a to point b.
So for example,
it turns out that the automobile and the
internal combustion engine are among the
most effective technologies ever devised
to transform the nature of the
atmosphere to heat up the world.
Not only that,
the car is completely transformed the
nature of cities,
and these were all unintended
consequences of the fact that the car
was far more than what people thought it
was.
You can say that about any technological
structure.
No one knew what TV would do to the
news.
For example,
no one knew what the Internet would do
to the music industry.
Everything that you interact with is far
more complicated than you see.
Yeah.
The most ancient ideas we have about the
nature of reality make are predicated on
a certain presupposition,
and the presupposition is this.
There's two fundamental modes of being
that characterize reality.
One is the absolute and absolute is the
sum total of everything,
so if you think about things in their
most possible form,
if you think of the things in their
infinite number of potential variations,
you can think about that as one pool of
reality.
It appears classically that people have
regarded their encounters with the
absolute,
which has all those multiple levels of
being that are beyond your perceptual
capacity as equivalent to an encounter
with God.
Now you know that in the Islamic
religion,
it's against the rules to make a graven
image of any sort of Mohammed,
right?
The idea is that you're not supposed to
make an image,
and among the ancient Hebrews the idea
was very similar.
The Dow is say that you shouldn't
confuse the moon with a finger pointing
to the moon and what all that means is
that the absolute is always something
that transcends the finite frame that
you place around your perceptions.
So as soon as you start talking about
it,
representing it,
making statues of it or idolizing it,
you lose your connection with the
absolute because you've turned it into
something that's understandable and
concrete.
Part of the wisdom traditions that the
world still maintains.
Make the constant moral presupposition
that you should always be aware of what
it is that transcends both your
understanding and your perceptions and
you should keep firmly in mind that that
exists.
Now.
When people talk about God in the modern
world,
they tend to think about something
that's more a.
That more has more of the
characteristics of a being,
and I suppose that's where most of the
debate about religious reality comes in.
But the idea that there's an absolute
that's outside of your perceptual
capacity seems to be to be merely a
statement of fact.
Especially given what we know now about
the nature of perception.
That the phenomena always transcends the
manner in which you frame it.
We've also come to understand that not
only does reality have multiple levels
of existence,
but in order to perceive it,
you have to stand inside multiple
frames.
This is a picture of a French city.
It's a walled city.
Now the walls are there to keep the
people in and the walls are there to
keep what isn't in the walls out,
and so you can think about that as a
protective structure.
Now I want to tell you how it is that
you still inhabit a walled city and
exactly what that means.
So for example,
you think about this room and I'm going
to tell you how it is that this room
allows you to see what it is that you
see.
Now,
when you're interacting with a computer,
you actually don't interact with the
computer.
You interact with the keyboard and the
screen.
If the computer crashes,
then you interact with the computer and
you find that as a general rule,
very annoying because you don't really
understand the computer very well and
you don't actually see how complex it is
until it stops working.
Most of the time when you're interacting
with the world,
you're doing things with the world.
You're interacting with it in a way that
produces some consequence that you want,
and that means in part that your
perceptions are always framed by what
you want and that's actually one of the
reasons why the world isn't just made
out of objects.
The world is made out of things you use
and things that get in your way.
Now you're always applying a frame like
that to the world in order to simplify
it enough so that you can understand it
and you're aided in this process by all
sorts of processes you really don't
notice because when you look at the
world,
you think,
well,
there are the objects,
but there's a thousand things going on
before you make that judgment.
So we'll look at this room.
When you walked in here,
the room tells you what to do.
The reason it tells you what to do is
because all the seats are pointed in the
same direction.
They're all slanted in a particular way.
When you walk in here and there's other
people sitting,
you can see all their faces point to the
front.
People's faces point towards what
interests the room is set up to make you
face the front.
The theory behind the room is that the
thing that's interesting in the room is
happening at the front.
It's a theater.
What's happening at the front is a
drama,
right?
Because theater is there to promote and
and and undergird drama.
A lecture is a dramatic act.
The room tells you what to do so you
don't have to think about what to do.
When you come into a room like this,
you can just do it because the room
tells you what to do and then you can
think.
You can sit in here in relative comfort
and listen to this lecture.
Why can you sit in here in relative
comfort?
Well,
the people around you have been
relatively carefully selected,
right?
As a consequence of analysis of their 12
years in school.
The university has made a determination
that they know how to sit down and
listen,
that hypothetically they're intelligent
enough to understand the lecture and
that they're very unlikely to disrupt
the proceedings with any unexpected
outburst of emotion or motivation.
Now,
if anybody broke one of those rules,
you can be sure that your eyes would
move very rapidly away from me and
directly towards the person who was
causing the trouble because that would
take center stage.
Now,
this room is actually supported by a
million invisible processes,
so for example,
while you're sitting in here,
you don't have to worry about whether
it's raining because there's a roof and
the roof is going to fall in because you
make the presumption that the people who
built the roof are competent and the
electricity works because the
electricity is the utility is run by
people who were competent,
so it's almost always on buildings
hardly ever burned down.
The electricity hardly ever fluctuates.
There's thousands of people out there
working as hard as they can diligently
to make this environment constant enough
so that you can ignore all the thousands
of things that you're ignoring so that
you can concentrate well enough to
attend to the few things that you are
attending to while you're in this room.
You're in a walled city.
There's multiple walls,
and those walls protect you from what's
outside the walls.
You can think about it this way.
This is a taoist image of reality.
Now people think about this as a
metaphysical symbol,
but it's not a metaphysical.
It's an unbelievably practical symbol.
The Dallas believe that the world,
the reality is made up essentially of
chaos and order.
Chaos is all those things you don't
understand,
so I would say that chaos is all those
things that exist outside of your
perceptual preconditions.
Order is all the things you do
understand and all the places you go
where the things that you do produce,
the results that you intend,
and the Dallas would say,
everywhere you go,
it's like that.
Everywhere you go has things that you
understand that or orderly and has
things that you don't understand that
are chaotic and the chaotic things
attract your attention because you
already understand the orderly things.
If something unexpected happened to your
nervous system,
automatically reacts to it,
orients you towards it,
and sometimes that can be catastrophic.
So this is an experience that some of
you will have in the next four years.
Undoubtedly there's a number of you that
want to go to medical school or to
graduate school or to law school or
business school,
and a certain percentage of you will
take the admission tests that will
determine whether or not you're able to
take that path and a certain percentage
of you will score below the 50th
percentile on those tests and that will
make and you will not be going to those
institutions.
And when that happens,
first of all,
you'll shake and tremble when you open
the envelope to find out your results.
And second,
if you haven't achieved the score that
you expected,
that you will achieve,
that you achieve,
your world will fall apart.
And what that'll mean is that you
descend from the domain of order into
the domain of chaos,
and that happens to people all the time.
It happens to people when they develop
an illness that's serious,
that they can't control because then
their body stops becoming something they
can predict and starts to become
something that they can't predict.
It happens to people when they're in an
intimate relationship and there'll be
trained,
they assumed fidelity and the person
tells them that they've had an affair.
That's chaos.
That means you didn't know who that
person was.
The future you imagine no longer exists.
Your perceptions of people are erroneous
at some level of analysis that you don't
understand.
It's conceivable that you're naive
beyond belief and that everything you
believed about yourself and other people
up to that point is false,
and when the revelation occurs that
knocks out one of the walls that support
to you and you descend accidentally into
chaos.
You'll regard that as one of the worst
experiences of your life.
When that happens to you,
your brain knows exactly what to do.
It stops thinking about the future.
It stops saving up resources for their
future.
It puts you in emergency preparation
mode so you're ready to do anything at
the drop of a hat because you don't know
what to do,
so your body prepares to do everything.
It shifts your cortisol levels up.
It activates your left and right a
quarter sees your limbic system and your
motivational systems are disinhibited,
turned on and you sweat and you can't
sleep because the orderly structure that
you thought you inhabited that provided
you with security and direction has now
disappeared from the Dallas,
believed that the world is always an
interplay between chaos and order and
that if you live your life properly,
you stand with one foot in order and one
foot in chaos.
Because if you're only an order,
nothing that's interesting ever happens
to you.
Nothing is anything but a repeat of all
of all the things that you already know.
That's the state that fascists desire
because fascist desire things to be
exactly the way they are forever and if
you're in a that's only characterized by
chaos.
You're at sea or overwhelmed or things
have fallen apart for you and there's
too much of everything for you to deal
with.
Now,
the Dallas being very wise,
people know other things as well and
they know,
for example,
the chaos can turn into order.
That's why there's a white.in
the middle of the Black Paisley and they
know that order can turn into chaos,
which is why there's a black.in
the middle of the White Paisley and the
Dallas believed that a meaningful life,
the optimally meaningful life is to be
found on the border between chaos and
order,
and I would say that your nervous system
tells you exactly when you are there and
it's a kind of place and you can tell
when you're there because you're secure
enough to be confident but not so secure
that you're bored and you're interested
enough to be awake but not so interested
that you're terrified.
And when you're in a state like that,
when you find things interesting and
meaningful,
time slips by you and you're no longer.
Self conscious is a medieval Christian
representation of the nature of reality.
On the outside.
You have the Virgin Mary inside the
Virgin Mary.
You have God the father and God.
The father was supporting a crucifix
with an individual on an individual,
and Christian thinking is Christ.
What does this image mean?
The walled city divides order from chaos
or order from nature.
We think about nature as the thing
that's outside of what we understand.
That's mother nature.
Mother Nature gives birth to all things.
That's the idea that's expressed in this
image.
So the Virgin Mary is standing for
Mother Nature.
Out of Mother Nature arises order and
tradition.
How it's true for primates like
chimpanzees,
as much as it's true for us,
any social animals that are grouped
together have to form an orderly
structure that they can inhabit together
that defines their boundaries and their
goals because otherwise they fight each
other to the death.
So in the state of untrammeled nature,
as Hobbes pointed out,
it's every man for himself and without
the order that tradition brains,
there is nothing but chaos and chaos is
murderous and unproductive.
When there's a problem with order.
If you look at the history of the 20th
century,
it's a tossup whether mother nature has
been harder on us or whether our
governmental traditions been harder on
us.
You know,
of course that the dictatorship of
Hitler killed 6 million Jews,
120 million people in the Second World
War.
The you may not know that the stalinists
dictatorships in the Soviet Union killed
an estimated 60 million people in
internal repression,
not counting those people who died in
the second world war and the internal
repression that characterized Mao's
communist China killed 100 million
people.
And so the problem with tradition is
that sometimes it's a wise king and
sometimes it's a king that eats its own
sons,
which means that although we need
tradition to guide us and to structure
even the manner in which we perceive the
world,
our traditions can become archaic and
outdated and cruel and inhuman,
and as a consequence they can pose a
threat to us.
Then chaos itself.
Nature or chaos is exactly the same
dichotomous structure.
The figure on the left is a medusa or a
Gorgon.
If you look at them and do so as you
probably already know,
you turned to stone.
The reason you turned to stone is
because when you look upon nature or
chaos without your normal veils,
it paralyzes you physiologically just
like a prey animal,
like a rabbit is terrified if it sees a
wolf for millions of years,
human beings were prey animals.
We were probably prey animals for large
reptiles,
which accounts,
for example,
for the reason that it appears that
primates like us are naturally afraid of
predatory reptiles.
If you're in the presence of something
that violates your assumptions of
safety,
you'll freeze it freeze so that the
thing that might eat you can't see you,
and that's what turns you to stone.
That's nature and it's terrible aspect
and the terrible aspect of nature can
freeze everyone and you can be sure and
we'll be seldom taught that you will
encounter that at some point in your
life.
The primary Buddhist dictum is that life
is suffering and what does that mean?
It means that because you're finite and
you're surrounded by something that's
absolute in a sense,
you're in a battle that you can never
win because there's always more of what
it is that you're trying to contend with
than there is with you and worse than
that,
and it's for this reason,
the tyrannies can't last is that the
thing that you're contending with isn't
even static.
It keeps changing so that what worked
for you yesterday won't necessarily work
for you tomorrow.
This is an l chemical version of the
Taoist Yin and Yang symbol and basically
it says something that's more
sophisticated and complex.
It says that the world is made up of
chaos and order.
Things that you can predict and
understand and things that you can't
predict and can't understand,
and inside the order there's some chaos,
and inside that chaos there's some order
and that order.
There's some chaos and so on and so
forth,
and equally the case for order.
You have mother nature,
representation of chaos,
sometimes positive,
sometimes negative.
You have a representation of the great
father that's security and tyranny to
things you'll always have to contend
with.
And finally,
in this representation,
you have a representation of the
individual,
at least a Christian representation of
the individual,
and that's Christ,
and it's a terrifying representation.
It's a remarkable representation because
it's not a representation of
transcendence,
it's a representation of suffering,
and it's a funny kind of representation
of suffering because the manner in which
the story unfolds is this,
Christ,
as the archetipal individual,
the model for individuals from a
psychological or mythological
perspective knows that he's limited and
knows that he's due to both suffering
and death in the garden of gifts.
Seventy the night before his
crucifixion,
he has an argument with God,
and the argument basically is a,
do I actually have to do this?
And the answer is twofold.
Well,
no,
actually you don't have to accept your
suffering,
but
you don't have to voluntarily accept
your suffering,
but there are consequences if you don't.
Now,
the Christian story is predicated on the
idea that if you voluntarily accept your
suffering,
you can cymbalta obviously transcended.
So remarkable philosophy.
And it's also something that we have
very good support for from a
psychological perspective.
So for example,
if I'm treating someone who has an
anxiety disorder or panic disorder who
can go out of their house without their
heart rate elevating and without
collapsing into a panic stricken heap
without visiting the emergency ward,
every time their heart rate accelerates,
every time they're in the subway,
every time they're in a mall,
so they're so terrified of existence,
they can't even get out of their house.
The Way you cure that person is by
getting them to voluntarily approach the
things that they're afraid of.
And it turns out that physiologically,
if I force you to accept a certain kind
of challenge,
your body will go into emergency
preparation mode and you'll become
stressed and that stress will cause you
physiological damage,
including brain damage.
If it's sustained for long enough.
But if I present you with the same
challenge and you accepted voluntarily,
your brain doesn't produce stress
hormones and completely different
physiological systems kick in.
And what that means is that people have
evolved to modes for dealing with the
unknown.
One is voluntary approach and the other
is panic stricken paralysis and flight.
In this representation,
you can see that there are crowds of
people standing in the wings of the Open
Statue Looking at the crucified
individual.
It's a very strange thing,
but you know,
you still see this,
you still see people doing things like
this that they don't notice.
I went to a museum in New York and there
were a very large number of paintings.
They're from the late renaissance and
they were all religiously themed like
medieval paintings,
except they,
um,
they featured recognizable individuals
and people had come from all over the
world to look at those paintings.
They were extremely valuable paintings,
you know,
they were painted by Michelangelo or
Leonardo Da Vinci.
And um,
each of them was probably valued for
reasons that are very difficult to
understand,
something approximating hundreds of
millions of dollars.
The late renaissance was the first time
in human history where human beings
dared to presume that sacred images
could be given an individual human face.
And that idea was actually what launched
the enlightenment and launched the
development of modern culture.
The late renaissance thinkers.
The artists in particular were the first
people to posit that there was some
direct relationship between these sacred
images and actual people and people come
from all over the world to look at these
paintings even though they don't
understand what they mean.
I want to show you some images that
describe how the idea of the suffering
individual developed and what that
means.
The first thing I want to show you is
this picture of St George and the
Dragon.
Now you know the main street that runs
through the university is named after St
George,
right?
This is a very old image.
I'm the oldest story we know,
which is a Mesopotamian creation.
Myth features a,
a God who confronts a reptilian monster
and makes the world as a consequence of
the conflict.
He faces her.
She's terrifying.
He cuts her up into pieces and one of
the pieces that makes the world now the
Mesopotamians 5,000
years ago,
we're trying to figure out what the
nature of individuality was and what the
nature of consciousness was and their
presupposition which was dramatized
because these people told stories.
They didn't think the way we think,
and in,
in an explicit philosophical,
logical meet,
uh,
with philosophical processes,
they thought in stories which is a
natural way for people to think.
They came to the conclusion that the
object of their ultimate worship was the
God who confronted the dragon of chaos,
cut it into pieces and made the world.
And that idea has echo down through the
ages.
It's an idea that human beings have
never lost.
Now this idea is very interesting,
so you see the castle in the background
and we already know what the castle
stands for.
The castle stands for order and it's a
multi walled castle because everyone's
protected by multiple walls,
but those walls are constantly breached.
Now,
young people,
especially modern young people,
are often very cynical about the
traditions that they inhabit.
They're cynical about them because they
see the fact that the world is
theoretically devolving into some kind
of environmental catastrophe and they're
cynical because they're still worn
because there's still hunger there,
cynical because often the people who are
teaching them the traditions don't seem
to believe in them themselves.
And it's very easy for young people to
look at the traditions that were and to
notice the brakes with the truth of the
matter is,
is that throughout human history,
tradition has always been an acronystic
and out of date,
and what you see in images of St George
and the Dragon is the dragon's always
breached the walls,
which means that tradition is always
under attack from chaos.
Well,
of course it is because the future is
different than the past,
but that doesn't mean that the past
should be abandoned because if you
abandoned the past and you knocked on
all your walls,
you fall into a pit of chaos and that
classically speaking,
is indistinguishably.
Indistinguishable from hell.
And I can tell you that if you spend
long enough in that state,
you'll become bitter and cruel because
that's what happens to people who suffer
endlessly.
St George is a different kind of
individual.
When the walls come crumbling down,
as they always do,
he decides to go out and to confront the
dragons.
Now,
dragons are very strange creatures,
as you may have already noted.
First of all,
they don't exist.
Second of all,
they have very weird propensities,
so for example,
they hoard gold and they tend to trap
virgins in their layer,
which you will also admit is very
strange behavior for a reptile.
Now,
the idea behind this is that it's very,
very complicated idea and it's all
presented pictorially.
The idea is that the thing that lurks
underneath,
if you look to the right of the picture,
you can see that there's a cave.
The cave goes way down into the ground
and way down into the ground is the
terrifying place that's underneath
everything.
The dragon crawls out from time to time
to threaten the structure of everything
that's known.
St George comes out to confront the
dragon,
voluntarily overcomes it,
and in this image
rescues the virgin that the dragon has
been guardian.
It's a very complicated story.
It means that the things that terrify
you contain things of value.
That's also what the image of the goal
that the dragon horns represent.
It means something else as well.
It means that the individual man who's
likely to go out and confront chaos when
tradition is crumbling,
is more likely to find a mate.
This is Jonah.
Joe and I had a very weird experience.
He was swallowed by a whale.
That's a very strange whale as you,
as you might well note.
It's a medieval whale,
and of course medieval people didn't
really know what whales were and so they
were guessing what a way it was.
And so a whale for a mid evil person
would have been a big fish,
would have been a squid.
That would have been some monstrous
thing like a shark that lurks in the
deep because they didn't have.
They weren't able to Segue,
segregate all those things out
biologically.
Their,
their powers of collective observation
weren't that good.
So the way off of them was what lurks
underneath in the darkness,
right?
And the idea with Jonah was that now and
then what lurks underneath in the
darkest rises up to swallow you,
but if your attitude is proper,
then you can come back out.
The other side changed.
Now that's a story of redemption.
So for example,
imagine that you are a,
we're in a bad relationship and maybe
you weren't that happy about it,
but you know it was better than no
relationship at all and then the person
that you are in a relationship betrayed
you and maybe they did that because you
actually weren't that happy with the
relationship anyways.
Maybe they did that because you're a
little bit naive or maybe they did that
because you were a little bit too easy
to get along with and as a consequent,
a little bit on the boring side.
And so when they first leave you,
it's a catastrophe because your world
falls apart.
But when your world falls apart,
you're somewhere new as possible to
learn something new in that place.
So you might learn,
for example,
that you should be a little sharper the
next time that you go out with someone
or you should be a little bit more
careful about picking up on clues that
your partner's board with you or that
maybe you should stop associating with
lying psychopaths and your life would be
a lot more positive and stop thinking
that you have the capacity to redeem
somebody that is not after redemption in
the least,
and what that means now and then is that
when you fall into the belly of a whale
and you're swallowed up by something
that lurks underneath that you can come
out the other side transformed and
that's actually how people learn.
Every time you learn something,
you learn because something you did
didn't work,
and that exposes you to the part of the
world that you don't understand.
Every time you're exposed to part of the
world that you don't understand,
you have the possibility of rebuilding
the structures that you use to interpret
the world.
That's often why it's more important to
notice that you're wrong than it is to
prove that you're right.
One of the things that you're supposed
to learn in university is precisely that
it might be useful to listen to people
that annoy you on the off chance that
they know something,
that if they tell you you can use
instead of dying.
Talking to people who agree with what
you say is like walking around in a
desert.
You already know everything that they
say.
The reason you're associating with them
in that situation is so that they never
say anything that challenges you because
you're afraid that if you go outside of
what you understand that you won't be
able to tolerate the chaos,
but it isn't the case.
People have an unbelievable capacity to
face and overcome things they don't
understand and not only that,
that's essentially what gives life its
meaning.
The Buddhists say life is suffering and
you think,
well,
if that's the case,
why bother with it?
And people do ask that question and they
ask it in ways that result in their own
destruction and worse in the destruction
of others.
So for example,
people who become particularly cruel,
particularly in a genocidal manner,
are more than willing to dispense with
as many human beings as they can
possibly train their sights on because
they're so disgusted by the nature of
human limitation that they'd rather
eradicated and lots of people become
suicidal because they can't bear the
conditions of their own existence and
suffering is real and it's inescapable.
So the question is what you do about it.
You notice in your own life,
and you can do this by watching your own
life.
I often ask my clients to do this.
Say,
look,
watch your life for a week and pretend
you don't know who you are because you
don't know who you are at all,
what you understand most about yourself
or the arbitrary presuppositions that
you use to him yourself and and you act
as if those presuppositions are true so
that the revelation of the full nature
of your character won't terrify you.
People hide in their own boxes and it's
not surprising,
but it's not a good idea because life is
too hard to hide in a box.
You can't manage it.
If you do that,
if you watch yourself for a week,
you'll see certain things.
You'll see some of the time that you're
resentful and annoyed,
and those are times when you're either
taking advantage of yourself or you're
thinking improperly.
Some of the time you'll be bored,
in which case you're either
undisciplined or you're probably
pursuing something you don't want to
pursue,
and some of the time you'll actually be
engaged in life and the Times that
you're engaged in life,
you will notice that your there,
right?
The distinction between subject and
object disappears when you're engaged in
something that you find meaningful.
The purpose of life as far as I can tell
from studying mythology and from
studying psychology for decades,
is to find a mode of being that so
meaningful that the fact that life is
suffering is no longer relevant or maybe
that it's even acceptable and I would
say as well that people know when
they're doing that.
You know when you're doing that in part
because you're no longer resentful,
you say,
Geez,
I could do this forever.
Right?
There's a timelessness,
timelessness that's associated with that
state of being from a mythological
perspective that's equivalent to brief
habitation of the Kingdom of God.
That's the place where you are that's so
meaningful that it enables you to bear
the harsh conditions of life without
becoming resentful,
bitter,
or cruel,
and there's nothing that you can pursue
in your life that will be half as useful
as that.
Your nervous system being an evolved
structure is evolved for a universe that
is composed of the interaction between
chaos and order.
Those are the most fundamental constants
that we know.
They transcend the mirror perception of
objects.
Everywhere you go is chaos and order.
Traditional Chinese doctors go into
people's houses to diagnose why it is
that someone in that house is suffering
and they walk in and they think he was
too much order.
Here,
I've been in houses like that.
That's a house where all the furniture
is covered with plastic.
That's a house where if you put a glass
on a wooden table,
the mistress of the house runs over with
the coaster,
slips it under immediately and gives you
a dirty look.
That's a place where the children never
play in the living room.
That's a place where the lines in the
carpet or vacuumed so precisely that
they're actually parallel.
That's a place where there's so much
order that no one can survive because
the person who runs the house is a
tyrant and then anyone who's in that
house is sick
because they're suffering from an excess
of order and then you can walk into a
house that's completely different and
you can even see this in your own room
if you want.
Everything's in complete disarray.
You can't even look at that place.
You're sick the moment you cross the
threshold because everywhere you look,
there's parts of untransformed chaos
yelling to you.
Do something about this loser.
If you walk into your study and you have
a stack of papers in the midst of which
is buried your homework,
you'll notice that you have a very tough
time looking at that stack of papers and
the reason for that is that the stack of
papers that you were ignoring that's
aging and causing you more trouble with
each passing day is a portal into order
through which chaos is flowing and if
you ignore that long enough,
the chaos will flow through that portal
and take over your room and then take
over your life and you might think,
well,
that's a very strange way of looking at
things and I suppose it is,
but just as an experiment to see whether
or not this is true.
Try Not paying your taxes for 10 years
and see what happens.
This is an old representation right
atlas with the world.
Well,
it's a representation that says that
that's the proper way to live,
right?
That the way that you live properly so
that you can withstand the nature of
your own being is to pick up a load
that's heavy enough so that if you carry
it,
you have some self respect.
That's a very weird idea because it's
frequently the case that people do
everything they can to lighten their
load,
but the problem with carrying a light
load is that then you have nothing
that's useful to do and if you have
nothing useful to do all you have around
you,
unless you're extremely fortunate.
If not,
we'll only be the case for very short
periods of time is meaningless.
Suffering and there's nothing worse for
your sold and meaningless suffering.
If you look around,
you see the people that you respect and
and I don't mean that you think about
respecting.
I mean the ones that you're got,
your whole being,
your embodied being tells you to
respect.
You'll see that it's always people who
picked up something heavy and her
caring.
It's successful.
You think now that's what it means to be
a human being,
and when you see that you can think,
well,
perhaps life is worthwhile despite the
fact that the essential nature of
reality is suffering.
There's an old Jewish idea and the idea
is that man and God are in a sense
twins.
It's a very strange idea,
but it seems to hinge on something like
this,
the classic attributes of God.
These are the attributes of the absolute
omniscience,
omnipotence and omnipresence.
Do anything be anything kind of
translate the other one momentarily.
There's a question goes along with that.
What is it being that's characterized by
the absolute attributes of God lack
and the answer that is limitation and
that's an unbelievably interesting idea
and the reason it's so interesting is
because one of the things that modern
psychology is increasingly telling us is
that without the limitation that a
creature like us with the structure of
our consciousness brings to bear on the
world.
There's no reality.
The reality is is an emergent
consequence of the interaction between
something that's painfully limited like
the US and whatever the absolute is,
which is something that is completely
without borders,
and what that implies in a sense is that
without limitation,
there's no being with limitation.
There's suffering without suffering.
Then there's no Ba,
well you might think,
well perhaps there should be no beating
and lots of people act their whole lives
in order to see if they can make that a
possibility and that's really a luxury
we don't have anymore,
but the alternative is to presume that
being is worth the suffering and to find
a mode of being that allows you to make
that claim.
In reality,
I would say in a sense that's your
existential destiny and if you're here
at university rather than a trade
school,
your job is to figure out how to be a
human being and that's a much more
important job than any specific time.
Limited concrete permit,
pragmatic plan,
you have an unlimited possibility for
good.
Really,
individuals are way more powerful than
they think.
They're more powerful for evil,
but they're also more powerful for good.
These archaic stories that I've been
telling you about,
they have something to say to you.
They say life is uncertain.
You'll never know enough and normally
that you never can do enough,
and not only that,
everything that you stand on is shaky
and then they say,
but you still have to stand on it and
while you're standing on it,
you have to improve it
and that's how life goes on and that's
how you live your life and if you forget
those things or if you undermine them,
you're in the same situation that the
unfortunate man was that I told you
about in the Old Testament who reached
out to touch something he should've left
alone.
To the degree that you're human,
you have to abide by a certain set of
truths.
The truths that I told you about today
are as far as I can tell,
something that's close to a minimal set.
There's chaos.
There's order.
You're stuck with both of them and they
both have a cost and they both have
advantages and your job is to figure out
how to serve as the appropriate mediator
between the two.
And you can tell when you're doing that
because when you're doing that,
the dismal circumstances of your life
manifest them selves to you as eminently
acceptable,
and it's in that situation that you know
that you've placed yourself in a
position in nature where everything is
in harmony and that's the place to aim
for.
Nice talking to you.
The first thing I would say is that if
you're dealing with someone who's
depressed and they're really depressed,
you should try giving them
antidepressants because if they die,
you can't help them.
Okay?
So if you're suffering,
you are obligated in a sense to hold
onto whatever roped someone throws you.
And one of the things I do with my
clients all the time,
especially if they're really in trouble,
is to tell them,
look,
I don't know exactly what's going to
happen.
Help you,
but don't arbitrarily throw out any
possibilities because you might not have
that luxury.
Antidepressants help a lot of people and
there are technical reasons why that's
the case.
So that's a simple answer.
It's not relevant to what I already
described except that if you're offered
a gift by your society and it works,
try it.
I don't care what your presuppositions
are.
Apart from that,
lots of lots of time,
lots of the time you see people who are
suffering with depression,
for example.
There's a multitude of reasons,
but I'll take one common reason.
Um,
you could think about it as associated
with the story of Peter Pan.
Peter Pan is someone who won't grow up
right now.
The problem with Peter Pan is he gets to
be king,
but it's King of Neverland.
Neverland doesn't exist.
So being king of nothing isn't that
helpful?
Well,
one of the things that you often see
with people who suffer from depression
and,
and not making a blanket statement about
the cause of depression because there's
lots of them,
is that people who don't have enough
order in their life tend to get
overwhelmed.
So for example,
if someone comes into me and see to see
me and they say they're depressed,
I always asked him a very standard set
of questions.
Do you have a job?
If you don't have a job,
you're really in trouble in our society,
first of all,
you,
your biological rhythms tend to go off
the rails right away because there's no
reason to go to bed at any particular
time and there's no reason to get up and
for many people,
if they don't get up at the same time,
they follow up the functioning of their
circadian rhythms and that's enough to
make them depressed right off the bat,
especially if they start napping during
the afternoon.
They don't also don't have a purpose.
People aren't good without a purpose,
and this isn't.
This isn't hypothesizing.
We absolutely understand the circuitry
that underlies positive emotion.
We know how it works.
Almost all the positive emotion that any
of you are likely to experience in your
life will not be a consequence of
attaining things.
It will be a consequence of seeing that
things are working as you proceed
towards a goal you value.
That's completely different and you need
to know this because people are often
stunned.
For example,
they finished their phd thesis and their
presupposition is that they're going to
be elated for a month and often instead
they're actually depressed and they
think,
what,
hell I'd been working on this for seven
years and I handed it in and what do I
do now?
And that's what depresses them,
right?
It's the,
what do I do now?
Well,
they're fine if they enjoyed it,
pursuing the thing,
as long as it was working out,
they get a lot of enthusiasm and
excitement out of that because that's
how our nervous systems work.
Most of your positive emotion is goal
pursuit,
emotion.
If you take drugs like cocaine or
amphetamine,
the reason they're enjoyable is because
they turn on the systems that help you
pursue goals.
That's why people like them.
So if you don't have a job,
you got no structure,
that's not good.
Plus you tend not to have a point.
So you're overwhelmed by chaotic lack of
structure and you don't have any
positive emotion.
Well,
do you have any friends?
So sometimes you see people who are
depressed,
they have no job,
they have no friends,
they have no intimate relationship,
they have an additional health problem,
and they have a drug and alcohol
problem.
My experience has been,
if you have three of those problems,
it's almost impossible to help you.
You're so deeply mired in chaos that you
can't get out because you make progress
on one front and one of the other
problems pulls you down.
So one of the things I tell people who
are depressed is like,
don't sacrifice your stability.
Get a job.
Even if it's not the job you exactly
want,
get a damn job.
You need a job.
Find some friends,
get out in the dating circuit,
see if you can establish an intimate
relationship.
Put together some of the foundation
litems that that are like pillars that
you're life rests on.
Well that's the practical thing to do.
So that's one example with regards to
depression.
Well the thing is you don't just launch
it on them.
You know,
you got to negotiate with the person and
you also got to teach them to negotiate
with themselves.
And this is something that's very useful
to know,
you know,
you can tear an eis yourself into doing
things,
but I wouldn't recommend it.
What I would recommend that instead is
that you ask yourself what you're
willing to do.
It's a really effective technique.
It's like a meditative techniques.
So for example,
you can get up in the morning and you
can take,
well,
you know,
I'd like to have a good day to day.
So I'd like to go to bed tonight without
feeling guilty because I didn't do some
things I said I was going to do and I,
you know,
I'd like to have kind of an interesting
day.
So you've got to fulfill my
responsibilities and I want to enjoy the
day.
Then you can ask yourself,
well,
okay,
what would I have to do in order for
that to happen?
That I would do?
And the probability if you practice this
for three or four days,
is your brain will just tell you.
They'll say,
well,
you know,
there's that piece of homework that you
haven't done for like three weeks.
You should knock that sucker off because
it will only take you 10 minutes and
you've been avoiding it and torturing
yourself to death for 72 hours straight,
and if you do that,
here's a little interesting thing you
can do and you know maybe this is a
little obligations you should clean up
and so what you do in a situation like
that as you teach the person to
negotiate with themselves say,
well,
let's figure out what your aims are.
You gotta have some names,
whatever they are,
and they might say,
well,
I'm so depressed I don't have any aims.
And then I say,
well,
pick the least objectionable of the Ames
and act it out for awhile and see what
happens.
Because sometimes your emotional,
your emotional systems are so followed
up that you have to pretend you have to
act the thing out before you can start
to believe it.
I mean,
people always assume they have to
believe in then act,
but.
But that's sometimes that's true in lots
of times.
It isn't.
So the trick,
if you're doing therapeutic work with
somebody and you're helping them
establish a structure,
is to find out what they'll do.
Now,
if they want to get better,
which is not a given because there are
often payoffs for not getting better.
That's basically the payoffs of being a
martyr or maybe the payoffs of doing
what you're entirely pathological family
members want you to do because they
actually want you to fail.
Assuming you want to get better.
There's usually something you can figure
out that would constitute a step towards
some sort of concrete goal.
And my presumption,
it's a behavioral presumptions
fundamentally is that small accruing
gains that repeat unbelievably powerful.
So this is another thing to know about
in your own life.
It's something I learned in part from
reading the writings of Alexander
Solzhenitsyn.
He was a great Russian philosopher and
novelist.
He said,
you can look at your life and you can
see what isn't right about it.
We know you have to do is look,
and then you can start to fix that.
And the way you fix it is by noticing
what you could in fact fix.
You know,
people are often trying to fix things
they can fix,
which I would not recommend because if
you try to fix something you can't text,
you'll just ruin it.
Like you can find all sorts of
undergraduates who are perfectly willing
to restructure the,
uh,
you know,
the international economic system who
cannot keep the room clean and there's
actually a gap there,
which,
and it's surprising that people don't
actually notice.
So I would say if you pay attention,
you can see things that you could fix.
They yell at you,
they really do.
We even know how that happens.
Let me,
let me give you an example because rooms
are full of stories and the stories have
have effects on you.
So here's a classic experiment.
So you take two groups of
undergraduates,
you bring them into your lab and you
give one group a multiple choice test
that has a bunch of words in it that are
associated with being old and you give
the other group the same multiple choice
test except the words are associated
with being young.
This is independent of the content of
the test.
It's just descriptions.
And then you time the undergraduate says
they walked back to the elevators,
the ones who read,
the ones who completed the multiple
choice tests that had more words
associated with aging,
walk slower back to the elevators and
they don't know that and they don't know
they're doing it and that that study's
been replicated in various forms.
Many,
many times.
You're unbelievably sensitive to the
story that your environment is telling
you because your environment is not made
out of objects.
That's just wrong.
Your environment is basically made out
of something like tools,
that obstacles you're a tool using
creature,
you a tool perceiving creature,
the things you like.
If I take you out of this room and I
said,
well,
what was in the room?
You're not going to say,
uh,
you know,
random patterns in the carpet because
they're real or just as good an object
as anything else.
You're going to say chairs because you
can sit on them and you're gonna.
Say handrails because you can hold them.
You can say stairs because you can walk
down them.
That's what you see.
And that's what you interact with.
And if you pay attention to your
environment,
which is you,
by the way,
extended all of your experiences,
you,
it will tell you all the time,
what you should do,
all you have to do is do it.
But then you have to decide if you want
to do it.
One of the things I've noticed about
people,
because I've wondered once I started
studying these mythological stories and
I got this idea about the fact that life
can be meaningful enough to justify its
suffering.
I thought,
God,
that's such a good idea because it's not
optimistic.
Exactly.
You know,
some people will tell you what,
you can be happy.
It's like those people are idiots.
I'm telling you,
they're idiots.
There's going to be things that come
along that flat new so hard,
you won't believe it and you're not
happy then.
And so if life is to be happy while in
those situations,
what are you doing?
Why are you even live?
But let isn't.
Life isn't to be happy.
If you're happy,
you're bloody fortunate and you should
enjoy it.
You should,
because it's the grace of God,
so to speak,
with regards to meaning,
I thought,
well,
people know when they're doing something
meaningful,
they can tell,
so why the hell don't they do meaningful
things all the time?
It seems obvious you could do it.
I mean it's hard,
you know,
because other people want you to do
other things and it's a struggle,
but everything's a struggle and then I
thought,
well,
oh,
I get it.
I see why it took me about 10 years to
figure this out.
People have a choice.
Choice number one,
nothing you do means anything.
Well,
that's kind of a drag,
right?
Meaninglessness of life and all that
existential angst,
you know,
that's kind of a pain,
but the upside of nothing that you do be
mean is meaningful is you don't have to
do anything.
You've got no responsibility.
No,
you have to suffer because things are
meaningless,
but that's a small price to pay for
being able to be completely useless.
The alternative,
the alternative is everything you do
matters.
Really,
if you make a mistake,
it's a real mistake.
If you be someone,
you tilt the world a little more sharply
towards evil rather than good,
it matters what you do well.
If you buy that,
then you can have a meaningful life,
but there's no mucking around.
It means responsibility.
It means that the decisions you make are
important.
It means that when you do something
wrong,
it's wrong.
Well,
do you want that?
See,
that's a very hard question because
people don't always mean the same thing
when they say their own moral compass.
Now,
so at here,
here,
here's.
Here's what I mean by that.
Technically part of the way,
the reason that you're able to
distinguish between right and wrong is
because you are a certain kind of
biological organism and then another
reason is that your head is full of
other people,
right?
All the people you've met,
all the people that you've interacted
with their own telling you a way to
behave that's good in a way that isn't.
There are circumstances under which your
conscience should,
the or the duty you have to.
Your conscience should override the duty
you have to social norms,
but before you break a rule because you
think you're going to be doing a good
thing,
you bloody well better make sure you
have your head screwed on straight
because every time you tell yourself a
lie and every time you act out a
falsehood,
you disturbed the pristine integrity of
your nervous system and the reports
it'll give you about the nature of the
world will be distorted as a consequence
of that.
So yeah,
you have a moral obligation to follow
the dictates of your conscience,
but you also have a moral obligation to
make sure that your life is straightened
out so that you can rely on your own
judgment and you can't separate those
things.